This video is brought to you by a news voice.
The news is broken almost all us media is owned by just a handful of big
corporations. Fake news is obviously a huge problem as well.
And finding something on bias can be hard.
News voice is revolutionizing the news landscape.
It's an app that gives you a personalized newsfeed by aggregating major news
sites,
as well as international and independent media giving some much needed balance.
Each new story shows multiple sources,
which are all tagged with their bias and perspective.
The news affects almost everything in our lives. What we hear and read shapes,
which persons we trust, what we eat, what we buy, how we vote,
even how we think news voices created by its readers. As you can,
upvote stories that you find interesting. So more people will see them.
It's essentially a democratized platform for news. Plus it saves you time.
You get all the news and all the sources in one app so that you can be better
informed. Oh, and it's totally free. Anyway,
get started with news voice today for free through the link below it's available
on both Google play and the Apple app store. And let's get into the video.
[Inaudible] together.
China and India make up a third of the world's population yet,
while it may seem hard to believe these countries have large areas of their
territory, where there is absolutely no one.
And one of those areas is the border between these two countries.
Streets.
We're talking about a 3,500 kilometer stretch that crosses the Himalayas and
where there are hardly any human settlements.
Basically there's the Yeti and not much else. In other words,
the Chinese and the Indians share a border,
but they don't see much of each other. And given what I've seen,
that's probably a good thing. Every time,
a Chinese border patrol and an Indian border patrol, cross paths,
they end up calling each other names and then beating each other up. And no,
this is not just a metaphor. It's very real.
We're talking about real fistfights.
There are a lot more common than you might think.
We're talking about two countries that have had a Rocky relationship for
decades. And this is especially worrying.
When we consider that we are talking about two nations that make up a third of
the world's population. In other words, news,
like this is a bit of concern to all of us because it could be the beginning.
By third world war
20 Indian soldiers killed in first deadly clashes with Chinese troops and
45 years.
And you're probably wondering,
but why do the Chinese and Indians get along so badly? Well,
the border that separates them is the subject of a never ending dispute.
Look at this map produced by algebra.
[Inaudible].
On the Western border is where the current class took place.
The Navy blue part is Kashmir.
Some of Kashmir is controlled by Pakistan and the rest by India in sky blue is
the science shin glacier seized by India from Pakistan in orange is the area of
AXA chin currently controlled by China,
but also claimed by India there in the Galilean Valley is where a deadly
confrontation recently took place.
But hold on a moment because the rest of the border is also a ticking time bomb
in the East is the Indian state of origin child Pradesh claimed by China as its
own territory since occupying Tibet and between Nepal and Bhutan,
there is a small strip of land, the ancient kingdom of Sikkim, which also.
[Inaudible].
In fact, Chinese and Indian troops clashed in this area in 2017.
And they clashed as usual equals a punch up. And I repeat,
this is not a metaphor. We're talking about one of the few cases of violent,
but not armed conflicts in the world. All fights are pretty scrappy.
And I know what you're thinking, really.
They really solve their problems with punches. Well, the truth is yes,
punching and diplomacy in 2017,
China's president Zhang ping and Indian prime minister Narendra Modi met in a
Chinese city. It looked like everything was going to be okay,
but the truth is all those good vibes have vanished.
And it seems there are cities in China that just seemed to attract bad luck
because yes, my dear friends of visual politic,
I bet you can't guess which city they decided to host this summit in,
see for yourselves.
Woo Han spirit has given new momentum to India.
China ties prime minister Modi.
Exactly. Move on like this deal was cast from the start.
And now in 2020 tensions between China and India are once again,
front and center in the media, just like the city of UConn.
So today's questions are to what extent could there be an open war between China
and India? What could happen with all this board attention today?
We're going to answer these questions, but first let's look at some history.
Colossal.
China and India are two civilizations that have had cultural,
religious and commercial ties for more than 2,500 years. In theory,
they are not doomed to be enemies, but the reality is they get along terribly,
especially since China occupied Tibet in 1950 and the two civilizations suddenly
became neighbors. So what's all the fuss about. Let's see.
The first thing to explain is that to bet is a vast and remote territory.
Tibet is where Buddha lost his lighter and the land mass is as big as South
Africa. That's about twice as big as France. If independent,
it would be one of the 25 largest countries in the world.
But as you can imagine, it is virtually unpopulated,
only two inhabitants per square kilometer. To give you an idea,
it's the same population density as in the Western Sahara. However,
the location of its borders has been the main cause of confrontation between
China and India for seven decades,
because like so many other international conflicts,
the problems arise once again, from the time of the British empire,
As we have explained in previous videos,
Imperial China always had implements over to bet,
but at the beginning of the 20th century,
the forbidden city of Beijing was not at its strongest.
So the British took advantage of the Chinese weakness and invaded Tibet,
but its interests was not to keep the region. Instead,
the British and the Dalai Lama came to an agreement.
The tele Dharma would rule an independent Tibet and in return,
the British would extend their domains of the British Raj in India at the
expense of Tibetan territory.
So what's the problem that back then there was no Google earth and the British
made a terrible mess with the maps.
How do you draw a border in the Himalayas without satellites?
Do you put a marker on the summit of Everest? What about customs?
Where do you put them? It seems foolish,
but defining borders in such a mountainous area is almost impossible.
And to all that explains the need for so many regions that are practically no
man's land.
On the West.
And border that of Kashmir.
There were some British maps that said the territory of AXA chin was within the
rule of the British empire of India,
but this was not the case in other British maps.
And the confusion continues to this day. Take a look at the current map,
the striped area, which you can see is as big as Switzerland.
It is officially part of China, but nevertheless, India claims.
The situation.
And on the Eastern border is clearer in 1914,
the United Kingdom and Tibet signed a treaty that defined the North Eastern
border of British India. According to what became known as the McMahan line,
this meant that's a bet gave the Aaron child Pradesh region to the British crown
run trial. Pradesh is a little larger than the Czech Republic.
And twice as big as the controversial acts I chin area.
The fact is that China protested and disagreed with the marking of this border.
But when India became independent in 1947,
it adopted the Mac Mohan line as its border with Tibet.
The Dalai Lama agreed but not China.
And China's disagreements became more pronounced after the communist regime
occupied Tibet militarily in 1950 and the magma hotline became the
direct border between the two countries.
The new political map was to challenge two competing interests.
On one hand China's aspiration to restore the ancient borders of Imperial China.
And on the other hand, Hindu nationalists wanted to preserve British Imperial.
Reporters.
During the 1950s,
both countries sought to avoid direct conflict and respected the McMahan line,
but tension returned to its highest level in 1959.
If you've seen our video onto bet,
you'll remember that that's the year China suppressed protests in Tibet at the
same time, the Dalai Lama fled to Tibet under the cover of night.
And where did he take refuge? Exactly in India.
As you can imagine that didn't make China.
Are you happy.
The way for the events of 1962, when a war between India and China was fought,
China swept to the battalions of India from the area. However,
the conflict had few territorial consequences on the Western border trying to
consolidate its dominance of AXA chin, but in the East,
it withdrew from the conquered areas of orange helper dash and retreated to the
McMahan line,
which today remains the border between the two countries since 1988,
China and India have met to renegotiate this border,
but they've never reached an agreement. While on the other hand,
they do not dare to face each other in battle. Again, either think about it.
India is a nuclear power and know their nuclear weapons.
Aren't just to defend against Pakistan.
Watch what bill Clinton was once told by the den Indian prime minister.
Have an overt nuclear weapons state on our borders, a state which committed,
armed aggression against India in 1962.
Although our relations with that country have improved in the last decade or so.
An atmosphere of distrust persists mainly due to the unresolved border
problem,
a tall [inaudible] Indian prime minister between 1998 and
2004.
China and India are in what we would call a Mexican standoff.
That is they can't stand one another, but neither side.
There's the start armed conflict because they both have weapons too.
No, you liked each other.
How did they resolve this standoff? Well, in the weirdest way,
you can imagine a punch up. And again, this is not a metaphor in the 1990s,
China and India agreed that their border patrols can be insulted,
beaten or spat at so long as there are no guns.
You may be surprised to hear that this deal has worked pretty well for decades.
Indian and Chinese soldiers have been able to vent their resentment,
but without any escalation, meanwhile,
India and China have been able to focus on more important things than
territorial conflicts that is on growing economically three decades later,
China has become factory to the world and India has become the world's service
provider. If you want to make things, you go to China.
If you want to hire programmers, you go to India.
The two countries have grown and territorial conflicts have faded into the
background.
So now you're going to wonder what happened in 2020 for the conflict to surface
again. Well, let's take a look at that right now.
Pearl necklace versus diamond necklace.
China's biggest antagonist is the United States,
but if there's one country that gives him a real headache, it's India.
If you've been following visual politics for some time,
you will know that in previous videos, we have explained China's sugar,
daddy diplomacy. In recent years,
China has not only invested in its belt and road initiative.
The so-called new silk road. They also invested in the so-called Pell necklace.
Those of you have watched this channel for a long time.
We know that China relies heavily on its imports of raw materials.
For example, 80% of its oil imports pass through the Malacca Strait.
And this means that they have to pass very close to the undermanned and Nicobar
islands.
These islands are populated by tribes that have barely had contact with the
outside world. The islands are of no concern to anyone,
but they have one very important feature. They belong to India.
That doesn't mean you'll see any Indian policemen passing these islands,
but legally they're Indian territory.
And that means India can send its army there. Wherever it wants.
India needs to do is to deploy its Navy through the Andaman sea,
to cut off the transit of all types of ships through the Malacca Strait,
suddenly China would run out of oil and many other raw materials.
And that's why China had developed its Pearl necklace strategy.
The strategy consists of a multi-billion dollar investment in different
countries with access to the Indian ocean China's UN would seek two highly
interconnected objectives.
The first would be positioned these countries in such a way that they could not
reject an Alliance in defense of Beijing's strategic interests.
The second objective would be to develop seaports in the Indian ocean that would
in theory, at least not have a military character, even.
So the economic weakness of these countries and their debts to China would make
it truly difficult for them to have the capacity to say no to Beijing.
This is what we on this channel called sugar daddy.
Legacy.
And I pay for all your whims, but in return, I make you totally dependent on me.
So China has already developed a Pearl necklace to surround India with its ports
in Sri Lanka will DBS Pakistan, Bangladesh. And so.
Malia.
You can imagine this strategy has not made India very happy first because as we
have explained to the antagonism,
they feel towards China has been enormous since the 1962 war second,
because they see China as a threat to their own economic growth.
Indeed India refused to join a trade agreement between East Asia and Oceania,
for fear of opening its markets, even more to Chinese products in new Delhi,
they see the trade deficit with China as too high.
That is India buys from China, much more than its sells.
And this trend grows more pronounced year after year,
but that's not all true Lanka.
And the Maldives Bangladesh and even Nepal are all countries that India regards
as being in its natural area.
Influence.
This way.
The Pearl necklace strategy is seen by India as China meddling in its diplomacy.
And if all this were not enough that icing on the cake is the friendship between
China and India's arch enemy Pakistan. In other words,
there are more and more reasons for India and China to not get on.
Therefore new Delhi has counter attacked with its diamond necklace plan,
a series of alliances with other countries in the region to allow the Indian
Navy access to some of its ports.
We're talking about countries as scattered as Oman. The say shells, Iran,
Singapore, or last, but certainly not least Indonesia,
especially this particular port in Sumatra,
because it would be essential to close the store.
Did military base in Subang Indonesia can strangle China at the streets.
India has also sought support beyond the Indian ocean.
It has strengthened the quad Alliance,
which includes four powers wary of Chinese awakening. We're talking about India,
Australia, Japan, and the United States in doing this,
it should be remembered that India is breaking with a decades long policy of
non-alignment with respect to global blocks. And you Trelegy.
They are clearly abandoning by betting on the U S lead block.
Washington has always had frosty relations with India,
especially since they developed their nuclear weapons program,
but it's been a long time. And now if the white house had to choose, it's clear,
they would switch.
India side.
Of course, the breaking of the ice between India and the United States.
Also the noise China,
but arguably the biggest afferents to Beijing is India's support for the Tibetan
cause the Dalai Lama lives in India and is China's public enemy. Number one.
So as you can see, woo Han spirit is already more of a ghost of the past,
then a hope for the future.
And that's where things were at when tension escalated in Ladakh.
Kashmir,
third world war.
Einstein said he didn't know what weapons would be used in the third world war,
but in the fourth sticks and stones. Well, he doesn't seem to be too far off.
Watch this footage from the end of May, 2020.
Yeah.
These soldiers are from the Indian army.
They just incepted a light armored vehicle from the Chinese people,
liberation army within their territory. And as you can see,
it's been greeted as if it were a tax inspector. They stoned it,
forcing it to retreat.
Two weeks after this video was released details of the deadly Galvon Valley
showdown were released, Chinese casualties were not made public.
What's more at the time of making this video.
It's not very clear where the injured Indian soldiers were beaten or got
hypothermia after falling into it.
[Inaudible].
What is certain is that we are facing the most significant clash in decades
between China and India. So why is this happening right now?
India currently has an ultra nationalist government.
One of its most controversial measures has been to remove Kashmir's autonomy.
They have said in Kashmir that they do not respond to anyone button new deli and
have dedicated themselves to reinforcing a number of positions in China.
This is seen as a threat to their claims on the exon chin region,
which is dominated by Beijing.
And that's not all India has mobilized troops near the border,
and we're not talking about a few soldiers to give you an idea.
They've built an airfield at a height of 5,000 meters with the highest runway in
the world. They've also built roads like this.
[Inaudible].
Road would make border positions more accessible to the Indian army.
And it seems that this may explain the Chinese interest in the gal. One valid.
Somebody to Del lot beg oldie road link makes gall one.
China took advantage of everyone's attention,
being focused on the pandemic and occupied some 60 hectares, belonging to India,
such a move is typically seen as a declaration of war.
But wait a moment because it seems that China took a step back after the deadly
clash and has abandoned its risky positions.
Why has Beijing acted like this possibly to give warnings to India?
Think about it. Decades ago,
China and India were two equally poor countries today.
China's economy is five times that of India. Of course,
India has grown a lot in recent years,
but China has grown a lot more and that is reflected in its military budget.
China has a much better armed army.
In India. However, India.
Still has an ACE up its sleeve it's allies. Again,
the United States is more likely to help India than China. In other words,
we are stuck in a Mexican standoff, India and China hate each other,
but are unwilling to face off against it.
Joe, how are they.
Going to solve this hatred? Well,
if the answer decades ago was throwing punches.
Now they're opting for something a little bit more civilized the economy.
So far, India has already bans Tik TOK.
We chat and 50 other apps coming from China. In addition,
it is considering imposing tariffs on more than 1000 products.
So what's the problem that within India,
there are those who want to avoid a trade war because they think it would cause
more damage to India itself than China. However,
there are some very influential entrepreneurs who have sided with the
government. Look at what Saigon Jindal president of the JSW group says.
JSW is one of India's largest industrial conglomerates.
See for yourself.
And my friends and cone industrialists are upset as their business with China is
important to maintain healthy margins and continuity.
But this situation has come because of our complacency in blindly accepting
cheaper imports from China rather than developing our own domestic vendors.
Meanwhile, China, India talks on the Lubbock continued,
so we will keep an eye on the upcoming developments.
But now the question is over to you.
Do you think that there will eventually be a war between China and India or do
you think that everything will more or less stay the same with more punches and
tariffs? Leave your answer in the comments.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Don't forget to check out our friends over at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that were not mine. Also.
This channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll be seeing you in the next video.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice, um,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or
Google play or your favorite podcast.